Ali abdal welcome to the show thank you
so much for having me this is going to
be fun and we've got your little your
little drinks over here which we can sip
on throughout the episode and we've got
your mechanical keyboard in front of us
as well I feel like we we're doing a lot
of chilling here we've got my book the
keyboard your
GS it's kind of nice because we're also
working with the same company to put
this stuff together it's just it's it's
cool that there is this sort of Creator
collaboration stuff going on now with
physical products I think so I like the
fact you know having something that is
my own that I spent so much time
building is so nice so that's brand new
right now when we're recording this this
tropical ice which is the white one
isn't out so this is going to be first
taste test for you it is ambient as well
so crack that open what does ambient
mean warm it's warm rather than chill so
have a crack of that and see what you
think oh it's very
nice that's a it cheers cheers yeah this
is my favorite flavor it's like
a it's a white Monster
killer yeah it was weird so um when I
tried this one for the first time
I was in LA and I didn't have much sleep
for like two nights cuz I had to I had
like a 8 a.m. meeting with my team the
next day and late nights and stuff cuz
like hanging out with people in LA and I
cracked up in one of these I I went to
the local we workor had one of these and
I genuinely felt so focused and my team
were literally commenting but yeah my
team would commenting you're like how
you have you got so much done cuz I was
just like Y and I'm not sure if it was
Placebo but like I just if it works if
it works it works so your new book feel
good productivity everyone needs to go
and buy that right now I know you've
spent an awful lot of time working on it
for a long time yeah why does feeling
good have anything to do with
productivity they're two words that
don't usually go together they don't
usually um but there is a large amount
of evidence that suggests that they very
much do go together so one of the
theories have you have you come have you
come across this the broaden and build
Theory no so this is the idea um you
know there's a psychologist called
Barbara Frederickson who in 2001 came up
with this Theory um it was based on
studies that showed that if you get
people into a lab and get them to do
tasks of creativity and then you split
them into two groups and you give one
group a candy bar or something and you
give the other group nothing for some
reason the group who gets a candy bar
comes up with more Creative Solutions to
whatever problem that they're trying to
solve and so the theory was okay there's
something about you know priming someone
with positive emotions that affects our
creativity and then they did you know
one one of the theories around this is
back in caveman times if for example
someone was experiencing positive
emotions that's usually a sign of safety
things are pretty chill things are good
and so when the cavemen are experiencing
POS emotions when they're feeling good
they are more inclined to go out and
explore so they're going to see what's
in that cave over there what's in that
Forest over there let me build my
friendships and stuff and so bar uh you
know Professor uh Barbara Frederickson
came up with this Theory called broaden
and build which is that when you feel
good when you experience positive
emotions it broadens the amount of
actions that are available to you and it
builds resources like social connections
and actual physical resources and stuff
whereas the converse negative emotions
if caveman human is feeling negative
emotions it's like [__] I'm stressed
there is a tiger on the horizon I need
to I I I I have a very small range of
options to choose from fight fly freeze
and I have to act within that
range and and so the idea is that
feeling good makes us more creative more
productive less stressed and boosts our
energy levels and there's so many
studies that that back all this up and
conversely negative emotions have the
opposite effect so very few people can
be creative and can perform productively
when they are feeling negative emotions
what is the link between creativity and
productivity cuz those two things don't
necessarily sound synonymous to me in
fact some of the most creative people
that I know like my housemate Zach are
really really unproductive the executive
function and openness seem to be
basically opposite ends of the same
Spectrum how are you squaring this
circle of creativity and productivity
yeah so for me productivity I'm I'm
defining as doing whatever matters to
you uh in a way that's intentional and
effective and you know ideally enjoyable
as well so for some people you know if
you are an artist then creativity is
productivity um and the studies that
they do don't on this stuff don't use
the word productivity they use the word
performance and so however you define
performance like studies in the
workplace performance is judged by
evaluations from your manager if you're
a writer performance is judged by word
count if you're a in in Creative tasks
performance is judged by how creative
you were so I kind of smuggle the two
concepts in together because I actually
think there is not that much of a
difference between creativity and
productivity depending on you know for
example if you're if if you're an
accountant then Creative Accounting is
probably unproductive because it's not
what you're trying to do but if you're a
knowledge worker if you're a writer if
you're a YouTuber whatever creativity is
productivity because it's literally what
you're trying to do and there's often I
guess uh Power law multipliers available
where you come up with a solution that
means that you can be more efficient
which requires you to probably be
creative ahead of that it's like if you
come up with a creative solution to a
productivity problem exactly yeah and I
think in in the world today like
especially people listening to this most
people do not have jobs where the goal
is to just crank out more widgets per
hour there is you know hosi talks about
this you know the people who are
billionaires are not working any harder
than you and me they're just playing
different chess moves yeah and often you
know finding the right chess move to
play means that you can get a 10x
outcome without working anywhere near as
hard as someone who's trying to work 10
times harder that was the Shan Puri
Insight his is a bit more controversial
where he says hard work is massively
overrated but the lesson is that it's
more important about what you work on
rather than how hard you work because
the correct decision if you say that
work done equals time times intensity
yeah but that's only within
Effectiveness yeah right like work done
is time times intensity but you can get
different outcomes based on how much you
leverage so all right you and me have
been friends for a long time you've
spent years writing this book and even
longer building up your Corpus of
productivity stuff on your YouTube
channel given that you've written about
about productivity why is it not filled
with Pomodoro Technique and time
blocking and how to build a good notion
template why is it not just a a tools
guide what why is it more feely yeah so
initially when I started writing this it
was more of a toolsy type thing because
you know as a productivity bro I love
learning about the tools and the
templates and stuff but I realized that
in my own life the thing that has made
me most productive you know people would
always ask how were you able to build a
YouTube channel in the business while
working as a doctor and you know that's
all demanding and stuff
and really this it was never because I
had a magical to-do list and when people
look at my phone they're like oh
actually it's it just looks like
everyone else's it's a bit of a mess my
to-do list is always overflowing it was
never really about that it was about the
fact that I found I consistently found
ways to make whatever I was doing feel
good I found ways to make whatever I was
doing energizing and enjoyable and it
wasn't always like that so when I
started off working as a junior doctor
in the NHS conditions were pretty bad
and they still are and I had this sort
of grindy mentality where I was I was
feeling drained every every day at work
wasn't enjoying it but my view was H you
know you just got to struggle through
this because everyone says the first two
years are the hardest and as long as you
struggle for long enough then on the
other side of that whatever that thing
is in in my case it was once I become a
specialist then once I become a
consultant once I hit some arbitrary
Milestone then my life will be chill but
then I would speak to people who were at
those milestones and their lives were
not chill either they were also having a
pretty terrible time at work and this
sort of made me realize wa wait a minute
I'm trying to juggle this full-time job
and build my YouTube channel my business
on the side I don't have any energy to
do this I do actually have time in the
evenings cuz I was only working 60 hours
a week and there's like another 50 hours
to play with but I just didn't have the
energy and it was when I started to
actively find ways to make medicine my
day job feel more energizing and
enjoyable that was what really unlocked
the energy to focus on my YouTube
channel and I spoken to you about this
sometimes where you managed to hit the
gym way more consistently than I do and
you also managed to record podcast way
more consistently than I do like at a
stupid rate of like three or four or
five per week but I suspect you don't
need to grind it doesn't feel like a
grind to you it feels like play I
suspect it feels good I've had to do
things to make it feel more like play so
especially when it comes to training one
of the things that I've had to do is get
a coach so for a very long time I
trained on my own very hard and that was
great but I'm 35 now and I've been
training for a decade and a bit and I
just can't push myself as hard in the
gym on my own as I used to when I'm
training with one of my boys I can if
I'm training in a class I can if I've
got my coach with me I can but on my own
I can't and I was like all right well
this seems to be a change in my
motivation setup so I need to account
for it so I got a coach so I'm training
with my trainer three times a week I'm
training in a class twice a week and I'm
training with one of my boys once a week
that's a six day week split wow um the
same goes for recording the podcast if I
was a YouTuber like you it would be
really difficult because I find sitting
down writing a script getting in front
of the camera all of that quite hard the
accountability I work very well with
accountability and also working in
groups or working at least with someone
the podcast is always with someone so I
guess I've learned one of the quirks of
me which is that although I work well in
solitude I'm most accountable when there
is someone waiting for it the same
reason if I was my journaling for myself
compliance is 50% but my newslet
compliance weekly is 100% right thousand
words a week for three years now right
nice every single week without without
stop rupturing Achilles it's holiday I'm
in Guatemala I'm getting my Visa
whatever like always done wrote it on
the plane from Peterson to the UK and
uploaded it on Plain Wi-Fi two days ago
right because I know that if I don't do
it people are going to notice so I've
realized that that is a motivation for
me um training is on the feel-good side
the other stuff is a little bit more
stick than carrot I suppose or at least
it's motivator rather than encourager um
but yeah finding the quirks of you and
then reverse engineering an environment
that allows you to tweak the very
specific knobs and levers that trigger
your motivation
that's I don't think that that's you
being a the David goggin inside of you
might say you should just do this
because you want like you should do hard
things and blah blah blah it's like well
yeah but you can do hard things in an
easier way yeah and that's what that is
absolutely so so there there's two
things I I would say to that so firstly
that's that's an amazing example uh the
third chapter of this book is all about
people and there is just stupid amounts
of evidence that says that the way that
we when whenever we work in a way that
involves other people it's just it's
more energizing it's more enjoyable it's
more motivating this is why people
benefit from accountability Buddies the
way I used to do it was at University I
found that if I was grinding away on my
own I'd be pretty miserable I I'd be
effective because you know I can I can I
can use I can employ discipline and
willpower to force myself to sit there
on my own and do my do my work but if I
go to the library with five other
friends we're all doing our work was it
pom sock that you used to do yeah the
Pomodoro Society we were like we would
do pomodoros together we would do 25
minutes of work we were all in different
subjects studying different things and
then 5 minutes of break and there's
something about doing it with friends
that just made the whole thing way more
enjoyable way more energizing and it
meant that I had energy in the evenings
to I don't know like hang out with
friends or like work on my websites back
in the day and I think this is something
that people don't think about enough
there is this idea that like oh I focus
better when I'm on my own it's like okay
you focus better when you when you're on
your own and there are very there are
some small number of people that are
just totally chill about that they never
struggle with procrastination they never
struggle with distraction they're just
able to grind it grind it out on their
own if you're that person and you also
having fun then great this advice is not
for you but for the rest of us for most
of us we you humans are social creatures
we benefit from the energy of the people
around us so finding a way to do
anything with other people makes you way
more effective and generally makes it
way more fun as well yeah it's it's a
delicate balance I remember I went to an
office for the first time in a long time
uh toward the back end of covid and was
reminded I I always used to think look
at how distracted I get when I sit at
the computer and that 5 minutes on
YouTube or that 10 minutes scrolling
Instagram or whatever like you see it
from the front row seat but I went into
an office and saw one person go anybody
want a coffee and then they go oh yeah
yeah have we got any of that blonde
roast left it's like no we haven't we
need to get some in oh okay what about
those Vietnamese World biscuit and you
realize that someone asking the whole
room if they want a coffee or not just
sapped 3 minutes out of everybody and 3
minutes isn't much but that's 40 times a
day right that's just always happening
over and over and over again so yeah I
think um the balance between not being
around people and not working with
people so that they distract you but
also realizing that it's a motivating
force is important all right so people
important having accountability buddies
also important where's power what's that
what's that come into yeah Power chapter
two so power is one of the key factors
that drives intrinsic motivation or
internal motivation uh so for listeners
who might not be familiar there's
broadly two types of motivation there's
extrinsic and intrinsic so extrinsic
motivation is when you are doing
something because of the external reward
you're going to get as a result or to
avoid some sort of punishment so um kind
of doing a thing because working a job
for the money is extrinsic motivation
intrinsic motivation is when you're
doing it for its own sake there is
something about the process that's
either enjoyable or that feels
meaningful to you and therefore you're
doing it for internal reasons for your
own reasons and basically all the
evidence shows that in internal or
intrinsic motivation is way more
powerful and durable than extrinsic
motivation and in fact the more
extrinsic motivation you have even if
you are intrinsically motiv at to to do
something extrinsic motivators often
crowd out intrinsic motivators how
so it's unclear but I I guess
anecdotally from my life I've I've
really seen this so back when my YouTube
channel was a side hustle I was
intrinsically motivated to make to make
videos and it would be fun and I'd be
you know sharing my message and making
videos and was I was having a great time
but weirdly as soon as sponsors starting
started paying lots of money for those
videos and now all of a sudden there's a
deadline on the video and there is like
a large amount of money attached to it
you would think that oh my God I could
make $20,000 by just filming this
YouTube video would make it way more fun
I get to do what I was doing before plus
$220,000 but what it actually feels like
is H this thing was once fun but now
I've got a deadline and now I've got a
boss and now I've got an Overlord you
turned your love into a labor exactly
and this is one of the problems with
monetizing your hobbies in that I my my
view is that if you monetize your
hobbies um for pocket money that's
really fun back when I was magician I
used to go around universitya doing
magic tricks and balls and [__] I was
paid £100 here and there that's fun I'm
not I'm not relying on the1 100 P to
live but if I had to be a professional
magician where I was relying on that
income to live now all of a sudden magic
stops being fun and you hear musicians
struggle with this all the time like you
know Ed Sheran used to enjoy music and
now it's become work and he cannot relax
like in the evenings he has to paint
because he has to find a creative Outlet
to recharge his energies because music
is now work so part of the problem you
know I'm I'm a big fan of monetizing
your passions and like fighting a way to
make a living out of it but there is
this sort of Fine Line in that the
motivation can sometimes become
extrinsic um rather than intrinsic but
coming back to power power is this idea
of autonomy and competence if you feel
like you have autonomy control
responsibility over the things that
you're doing and you feel like you are
actually good at the things you are
doing that leads to this feeling of
empowerment this feeling of power which
is a huge factor of intrinsic motivation
how can people make themselves feel more
autonomous a lot of people have got some
sort of accountability
of some kind that they need to be
reporting to what's the solution so
there's like a spectrum of uh of
autonomy um you can basically be you can
basically have control over three things
you can have control over the outcome
you can have control over the process
and you can have control over the
mindset outcome process and mindset so a
lot of people don't have control over
the outcome like when I was a doctor I
didn't have control over the outcome I
had to do what I was told I couldn't
just choose that I can now as an
entrepreneur and stuff but like you know
most people are not when a patient comes
in to see you and instead of diagnosing
them paint with them or something yeah
like I'm not allowed to do that so I I
have to do the things that I'm told also
I was Junior I had to doal with the
senior one all this kind of stuff but
even when you don't have control over
over what you're doing you have enormous
control over how you're doing it and so
what I realized you know the the first
few months where I was working as a
doctor I made the mistake of thinking
the way to conserve my energy is by
doing the bare minimum I made the
mistake of thinking you know what I'm
just going to do I'm just going to do
what I'm told I'm going to grind out out
these couple of years and let me just
make sure I I get home with enough
energy to film my YouTube videos but
weirdly approaching anything with that
level of half lastness really drains our
energy it is not fun looking at the
watch is not fun it's not a fun way to
go through your workday when you're like
okay I'm just going to do what I'm told
right I'm just going to do it I'm just
going to I'm just going to grind it out
and kind of the realization for me was
was weirdly on weekends on weekend
shifts I felt weirdly more energized
afterwards which is kind of weird
because weekend shifts as a doctor are
like more busy because there's fewer
there's fewer staff there's more
patients more emergencies [__] is going
on but I felt weirdly energized and I
realized it's because on weekend shifts
I was taking responsibility and I was
taking more ownership of the things that
I was doing the way I was approaching my
patients was thinking [__] the bug kind
of ends with me because I don't want to
ring up the consultant so I'm going to
I'm going to chase with these blood
results I'm going to call Radiology I'm
going to do the things and so I was
working harder but because I had I felt
like I owned the process of what I was
doing suddenly I had more energy and
work became more fun and the shift
absolutely flew by to the point that I
was like swapping with colleagues to be
like hey can I work a weekend because I
was like it's so much more fun working
on a weekend and what about mindset
mindset is there's really really good
blog post by Seth Goden uh that I've
read years ago that I I still think
think back to which is there is an
enormous difference between I have to do
this and I get to do this and whenever
we find ourselves thinking H I have to
do X we can always do a reframe in our
minds I choose to do X I get to do x i I
am blessed to be able to do X and even
just that like this is my single biggest
practical takeaway for anyone listening
to this the next time you feel like H I
have to do something just change it up
in your head you don't actually have to
do anything everything is a choice sure
there are consequences to all choices
and all that crap but fundamentally you
are choosing to do it and if you take
that ownership and switch it around in
the mind the mind is a powerful device
the mind can the the way we think about
something profoundly changes the way our
physiology responds to it the way our
body reacts um there's a there there's a
cool there's a cool way that
sociologists measure life satisfaction I
think we were talking about this on the
ifs stage um for for people unfamiliar
so one way of measuring life
satisfaction is by giving someone a
survey and being like how satisfied are
you with your life but then you know
people are self not self-aware they
don't really know what what's going on
but the other way that sociologists do
it is they have a little pager or I
think it's an app these days and they
ping you a few times a day and they ask
you one question they ask you if you
could would you choose to fast forward
the experience that you're currently
having to get to the end of it so for
example if you're at work would you
choose to fast forward to the end of
your workday if you're on a flight would
you choose to fast forward to the to the
end of flight if you're I don't know
putting your kids to bed would you
choose to fast forward that so that
they're already asleep and they look at
What proportion of your day would you
choose to fast forward and what they
find is that like you know the people
who would choose to fast forward a large
proportion of their day uh you know
that's a that is a an indicator that
actually you're not that satisfied with
life because you would rather not
experience a big chunk of your time than
experience seems like a great definition
and so what I've learned to do is I I
ask myself this question a lot if I ever
find myself like waiting in line for
something or I don't know I'm in an Uber
and I'm like I just want to get to my
destination or whatever the thing might
be or or even doing work that I I don't
quite enjoy I think what I fast for with
this and if the answer is ever yes I
know that there is a mindset shift I
need to make because I know that someone
you know if eot tol was in that position
he would be able to freaking enjoy the
process so why can't I and I find
switching from a half to to I get to is
incredible for making me feel more like
I I have autonomy therefore I have power
therefore I feel good so much comes back
to gratitude man it's like it's
so giving an answer that people already
feel like they know is way less
pioneering and and and like revelatory
but yeah gratitude just seems to be such
a solution it's it's a prophylactic
against life not being the way that you
want it to yeah switching the it's also
a treatment yes yeah true like five
minutes of gratitude journaling has the
same impact as doubling your income in
terms of Happiness levels wow and so
honestly just being more grateful and
being like yeah what a time to be alive
what is that phrase from Kurt vona which
is something to the something to the
effect of as you go through life remind
yourself on multiple occasions if this
isn't nice I don't know what is nval uh
if you won't if you can't be happy with
a coffee you won't be happy on a yard um
yeah just and I I like the fact that you
know you're thinking about
how can we find in the mundane how can
we find ways to not only take control
from a a performance perspective where I
know that if I switch this mindset I
will be happier but also it's actually
the way that you enjoy your life like
moment to moment forgetting the outcome
that you're going to get on the other
side of this from a productivity
perspective and as a side effect you'll
also be more productive but kind of and
the point of the book really is that
what I'm hoping people will do is that
they will read it because they want to
be more productive but what they will
find as a result of the because most of
the research in here is really from
positive psychology rather than from I
don't know organizational performance
design and stuff because what what I
found through doing all this research is
yes I'm more productive when I feel good
but also I am just happier and more
satisfied life and I feel good and that
is actually an inherent good so the goal
is not actually to get more done the
goal is to generally be more satisfied
and fulfilled with life well ultimately
the reason I think that people want to
be more productive is that they presume
on the other side of their increased
productivity would be a life that
they're going to enjoy more I'm going to
have more fun I'm going to be more
satisfied I'm going to be happier okay
well there is a shortcut to get there
which is just be happier in the moment
do the things that maximize happiness
now and then the productivity can either
come along for the ride or not so funny
man that you know you you set off to try
and write this thing and begin this
journey of productivity as a a solution
first off to being at Uni and being a
med student and then being a doctor and
then being a doctor with a business and
then being a doctor with multiple
businesses and what you ended up doing
was almost completely throwing
productivity out the window and
realizing that it's just one of multiple
different triggers and levers that you
can pull to get satisfied with life yeah
and that emotions are like the Baseline
of this whole thing I think earlier on
in my productivity broess I really uh
underappreciated the importance of
emotions CU I was pretty un I still to
to this day pretty un self-aware of my
own emotions and like what was going on
yeah me too but it was when I got
punched in the face with this like
working freaking 60 hours week in the
NHS where people are dying and where I'm
potentially responsible for some people
dying and like oh if you make a mistake
like you think about it all night I was
like oh [__] you know all the stoicism
has has not prepared me for this
onslaught of negative emotions yeah and
the solution to that was finding a way
to make to make everything feel good
okay what about play play is the first
chapter uh play I think is really fun so
um there's a lot of Nobel Prize winners
who attribute their success to the idea
of play um the guys that invented
graphine uh Richard feeman who invented
the atomic bomb well who helped with the
atomic bomb and then won a Nobel Prize
you know Richard feeman at one point was
feeling totally burnt out in his career
he was a physics Professor he was like
he got all the accolades he ticked all
the boxes but he did not enjoy physics
he he felt burned out by it and there's
this really cool story in his in in his
autobiography where he talks about how
at the Cornell University cafeteria a
student was chucking a plate up up in
the air and finman noticed that the
Cornell logo was like rotating at a
slightly different rate than like the
center of the plate or some [__] like
that and he was like wait a minute why
is the logo on the out of the plate
rotating differently to the inside of
the plate and he was like uh I don't
really care you know I'm you know I'm
I'm the professor I've invented the
atomic bomb this is not this is not this
is not significant but then he kind of
reminded himself that actually why did I
used to enjoy physics I used to enjoy
physics because I treated it like play I
did things just for the fun of them and
so he set out to model the equations of
how this bloody plate would rotate and
his colleagues were like dude what the
hell are you doing you're supposed to be
the great Professor Richard fman and
you're like writing equations about a
freaking wobbling plate and he would
respond with I'm just doing it for the
fun of it there is no there is no use in
it whatsoever and actually what happened
is that a he developed his love of
physics back again he cured his burnout
and he ended up the the wobbling of that
plate ended up leading to the equations
that helped him win the Nobel Prize
who's Alberto Lopez Alberto Lopez is
this uh climbing uh he was one of the
Olympic climbers and rock climbing in
the Olympics is is an interesting sport
because if you watch on TV you find that
they're all they all look really happy
which is in sharp contrast to like the
sprinters who look like really stressed
they're focused on this one goal and
like whereas rock climbers seem seem to
be having a laugh having a joke even
though they're competing in the Olympics
and competing against each other they're
like kind of pointing The Roots out to
each other and they seem quite happy
about the whole thing and rock climbing
was how uh mihi chicks at mihi who
discovered the concept of flow back in
the 1970s um you know this idea of Flow
State he noticed that you know rock
climbers get into this weird Flow State
where they feel like they're fully
engaged but this but but they view the
stakes as being as being low and that
combination of full engagement with
sufficiently low stakes is what creates
that feeling of play and can often what
create and and often what creates that
feeling of flow and so this gets at the
idea of like how do we experience more
play in our work and in our lives one of
the big answers is to just lower the
stakes so for example Roger fedra when
he's playing The Wimbledon final
especially when he's defending his title
he probably is not not feeling that
playful about it because the stakes are
too high it's really serious the stakes
are too high whereas you know most of us
are not in that kind of situation a lot
of the time and most of us when it comes
to our work if we can find a way to just
dial down the seriousness approach it
with a bit more sincerity as alen WS
would say d you know lower the stakes
lower the bar think of it not as this is
a big thing I'm trying to do but instead
think of it as I'm just having fun here
that is often how people perform way
better and feel more playful about their
work from a tactical perspective
how do you feel less serious about your
work especially if you care about it if
you're the sort of person that can
listen to me and you waffle on for a
couple of hours about productivity you
probably care about the outcomes that
you're getting in your life which means
that you might apply due or undue
pressure to the outcomes that you're
going to get yeah how can someone
tactically lower the stakes okay good
question I have uh three strategies
number one is to there's a great phrase
from Alan wats he he he calls his he
calls it sincere not serious
um no one wants to play a board game
with someone who's too serious about it
it's just not fun like they take you
know stickler for the rules it kind of
drains everyone's energy but you also
don't want to play a board game with
someone who's completely uncaring
because it's like well what's the fun in
that like they're not even trying you
want to play with someone who plays
sincerely and
so I think that phrase itself sincere
not serious if we find ourselves feeling
a bit stressed feeling like the the the
stakes are too high often that's where
procrastination and distraction kicks in
where we're like there's this emotional
hurdle of like this this thing is
writing a book is like a hard thing it's
a book and a book is a big deal that's
where we find ourselves getting
distracted and looking for the dope mean
hit on Tik Tok or whatever the thing
might be thinking let me just genuinely
approach this with sincerity rather than
seriousness is tactic number one that I
find super helpful tactic number two is
by you know at the start of each day I
ask myself one simple question and that
question is what is today's adventure
going to be now this speaks to the idea
you know it's a fairly common principle
in Psych in Psychology and performance
research that
making a plan at the start of the day is
a very useful thing to do some people do
it the night before most people do it in
the morning if you can figure out what
is your most important task you know
Brant Tracy calls it eat that frog
what's the one thing that if you got
that thing done today today would be a
win the adventure question is basically
that but framed in the in the language
of Adventure because if you think of
anything as an adventure you can ask
yourself the question what would this
look like if it were fun this is so
similar to Tim F's question of what
would it look like if it were easy but I
reframe it I have a posted note on my
computer monitor what would this look
like if it were fun because if you frame
something as an adventure and just
genuinely ask yourself how can I make
this fun you'll the mind will inevitably
come up with loads of different ways to
make this fun um so that's another
tangible thing what would this look like
look like if it were fun for me
personally what I found is that
everything becomes more fun when I have
background music preferably from like
Lord of the Rings concerning Hobbits the
Shire theme tune that kind
of the fact that you have a girlf friend
continues to amaze me mate turning hobit
Lord of the Rings when I was so when
when uh when when I had all these
realizations right feel field good
productivity I
realized part of why working in working
in a doctor's office is a bit Grim is
because the environment is just it's not
nice it's like the NHS doesn't have much
money I got this 20 quid Bluetooth
speaker from Amazon I attached it to the
light on the ceiling and I would just
play movie soundtracks while I was
writing my discharge letters and
initially the Consultants would come and
be like what the hell's going on here
but then they would be like oh I get it
yeah it's Harry Potter it's Lord of the
Ring parts of the Caribbean they would
recognize some of the songs you know a
bit of I don't know hand Zimmer every
every now and then and even just having
music in the background makes it feel
more playful just makes it more fun and
so what I'm trying to do here is
encourage people we can all like yes not
everything has to be fun all the time
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is we can always find ways to
make everything we're doing just a
little bit more fun approach it with a
little bit more play and yes that means
we'll we'll be more productive but
that's also not the point the point is
we'll just feel better about life yeah
it's I'd love to get you to sit down
with hosi uh at some point maybe over
the next year I'll I'll manage to get a
round table between us for dinner or
something because Alex seems to
deprioritize he finds fun in in the
grind um but it's his uh like executive
function and grind muscle is so
hypertrophy that he's just prepared to
continue to smash that lever um but I
would be interested to know what would
happen if you took a an inventory of his
or anot of his particular productivity
work setup and said hey why don't we try
like giving you a window or why don't we
try like this or that or the other I'd
be very interested to know just how
robust whether there's people for whom
this doesn't uh apply quite so much
something tells me that we need to be
careful taking uh Global advice from
people that are absolute outliers within
their performance it seems like this is
a much more like Normy middle of the
bell curve
solu you know what I mean like you know
LS and LS of the people that we know
that are outliers would still benefit
from this uh I think this this is where
you know I've I've I've listened to your
interview with David Goggins I've read
both listen to both his books they're
great I love I love the guy but David
goggin's thing I think is like he he's
an outlier there where everything is
about discipline you know he was telling
that story about how Goggins woke up at
3:00 in the morning and just genuinely
going for a run because that's the sort
of guy he is and what I worry about is
that normal people who are not David
Goggins will then think oh [__] I'm just
not disciplined enough I just need to
get more discipline I just need to grind
harder I just need to wake up earlier
and all that all that stuff and for a
very small subset of people that works
but for most people you know human
psychology is not geared towards
continuing to push yourself and you know
wake up at 3:00 in the morning just so
you can go for a run and continue to
cause pain to your like gogin freaking
runs Iron Man's with broken legs human
psychology is not geared for that and it
is literally trying to it's it's like
trying to play Life on hard mode and I
think I love the message that David
gogin shares but it's also not realistic
for for a lot of people like a lot of us
broadly if you ask people why they do
what they do they they do the things
that feel good no one struggles with
discipline or motivation to watch
Netflix or to play video games or to
hang out with friends because it just
freaking feels good you probably don't
struggle with discipline and motivation
to do podcasts because it feels good to
you correct I most of the time don't
struggle with discipline or motivation
to make YouTube videos or to write
because it feels good to me I actually
do struggle with podcasts especially
over zoom and I find that drains my
energy and which is why I'm less
motivated by that I struggle with the
gym because I've yet to find a way to
make it feel good consistently
especially while traveling we do the
things that feel good and so if we care
about work we can find ways of making
whatever matters to us feel good well
you can more robust wave yeah you could
imagine feeling good as a a force
multiplier to your discipline like that
you have this tank of it and you can get
either one mile per gallon or 100 miles
per gallon based on are you driving
uphill I.E not enjoying it or are you
driving downhill I.E this is enjoyable
to me absolutely I think this is where
discipline comes so this is how I Square
this idea of discipline because I I do
value discipline I think with any
task I it's it's exactly this hill
analogy that that you're talking about
that I think of it if you if you enjoy
the process it feels like going downhill
if you don't enjoy the process it feels
like going uphill going uphill obviously
requires you to exert will exert Willow
and discipline over the long term but
the the key thing is before anything
there's a bit of a hump even before
something that feels good there's a bit
of a hump like for you going to the gym
feels good but still a bit of a hump to
actually just get there because maybe
you're feeling a bit tired waking up on
the morning yep exactly it's always cold
I got to wait for the Uber and as long
as we are employing discipline to just
get over the hump that is a great use of
discipline because that is very
sustainable like just using discipline
in small doses to get started with a
thing that you want to do but to use
discipline and willpower to keep going
with a thing that you want to do oh
that's so draining that's so taxing yeah
we definitely need to be careful and
dude I you know I've contributed to this
I've sat down and nodded at David
Goggins and hosi and Joo as they've said
things that are similar to this but we
do need to be careful about the heroic
narrative that discipline in face of
misery and suffering gives right because
it is a heroic narrative and there will
be days when life comes and smashes you
in the face and when you need to have
built up that discipline muscle
sufficiently but finding the balance
between that not being so at Fe that it
can't be deployed but you're not using
it unnecessarily when there is a simpler
more enjoyable route toward achieving
the outcome that you want is is very
very difficult and it can't be
synthesized into do hard things even
when or especially when you don't feel
like it right like it's I can't Hamer
this into a meme yeah um but it is it's
holding two relatively conflicting views
in your mind at the same time discipline
is important and I should continue to
use it so it doesn't evaporate and I
should use discipline as little as
possible in my day-to-day Life by trying
to design the things that I do to be as
enjoyable as possible so that discipline
is not something I rely on it just
happens easily and naturally to me
absolutely I think there's you know I'd
be I'd be interested to get horos take
on this but one thing that he said that
really struck with me is when I was 20 I
wanted to be a millionaire when I was a
millionaire I wanted to be 20 yeah
and you know I'm a millionaire now and I
actually don't want to be 20 because I
feel like I enjoyed the process C of
getting there and I would love to live
my life not wanting to go back because
actually I have just enjoyed every step
of the
journey probably means I'm not going to
be as successful as hos is financially
but I depends on what the criteria of
success is BR depends absolutely depends
on what the criteria of success is I'm
sure Alex would have a more neon take on
this but obviously I I get that you know
it's a nice quote it's a nice sound bite
I I do Vibe with the sentiment behind it
but I think enjoying the journey while
also striving towards whatever goals you
have is literally the point yeah I what
are you optimizing for is just such a
great question uh my newsletter a couple
of weeks ago I had Morgan howel on the
show and the guy is just [__]
phenomenal right this quote that I've
been playing with for a long time from
spolski hubman shared it dopamine is not
about the pursuit of happiness it is
about the happiness of pursuit oh nice
so much of life and enjoyment is about
the anticipation of things coming in
fact the anticipation is often actually
more enjoyable than the experience
itself Tim Ferris used to book weekl
long holidays years and years in advance
so that he could get as much enjoyment
out of the anticipation as he could this
put a new perspective on it's not the
journey it's the destination there
actually is no destination each arrival
at the destination simply marks the
beginning of another journey toward the
next destination Morgan hous told me on
the show the other week he planned this
big holiday with his family for a long
time they've got kids they finally did
it after booking time off from
collaborative fund and from his writing
and wife and children and travel and all
the rest of it he arrives at this hotel
and on the first night that he arrives
there steps out onto the balcony if this
place he's been planning for ages the
first thought in his mind was it' be so
good if we came back here next year like
this place would be so good to come back
to next year so literally during the
experience of the destination he was
artificially creating another Journey
already I I had a really I had I had a
really Stark realization of this in a
really trivial way recently um one of
the okay uh there's a few a few
different re so what one the questions I
think about a lot
is what would I do if money were no
object and if money were No Object how
would I change how I spend my time and
one of the things that I often land on
is I'd actually probably play more video
games you know I really enjoyed video
games when I was a kid I'd love to you
know have a bit more time to to play
video games and I was mentioning this to
to my team who who were traveling with
me and they were like yeah but you don't
play video games that much like what's
what's what's going on there but I spend
a lot of time anticipating the joy of
playing video games and I I get so much
joy out of like you know what I I want
to buy the highest end gaming laptop
imaginable it is it the razor blade
18inch or the Alienware 18inch I can
afford that now cuz you know I've got
I've got merch guys buy my book please
yeah yeah yeah um but in the past I was
salivating over like a £5,000 gaming PC
and the anticipation of six months of
doing the research and watching the
videos was so joyful and then I got it I
was like I mean I'm never going to turn
this thing on because I actually have
more more fun in my work so there's
something profound like even now know
that if I buy this laptop I actually
won't use the enjoy going to stop the
enjoyment goes away I'm like okay well I
I guess I go to play video games now but
the anticipation of like I could buy it
whenever I want is is a thing I'm
holding on to because it's just free
happiness points for literally zero cost
yeah well that Tim Ferris hack of
bucking holidays years and years in
advance so good you know there was a a
study done on a I think it was British
clubbers so the same way that they
pinged people's phones in your earlier
example asking what's your level would
you fast forward this one was how happy
are you you'd think throughout the
entirety of the day leading up to the
night out then the night out you know it
might
be 12 midnight before they're so drunk
they can't remember anything but just as
the DJ starts to really ramp the setup
and the lights are going and the bottle
service is in or whatever it might be
but it wasn't the time that they had the
most fun throughout the entirety of
their day and night of a night out was
when they were getting ready together in
the house it was in anticipation of the
event it was not the event itself and
just continuing to remind myself
dopamine is not about the happiness it's
not about the pursuit of happiness it's
about the happiness of pursuit right
like you have to find enjoyment in the
journey because there is no destination
every single time that you reach a
destination it's just the way marker of
the next Journey that you're going to do
and even in the sort of people often say
that like oh you know you shifted the
goal poost when you got there but you
actually become a totally different
person on route to the destination like
if someone is trying to I don't know
make money on the side and they're like
oh my God like if if if only I could
make $2,000 a month of of of passive
income that would completely change my
life it's like yeah it would but by the
time you get to ,500 a month $1,500 a
month of passive income you have become
a fundamentally different person you
have a new set of skills you have a new
set of hopes beliefs expectations you
have way more self-confidence and now
suddenly 2K doesn't seem like much
you're like hm 10K I know people have
10K month passive income and by the time
you get you're like well you know that's
not 100K yeah and the gold post keeps on
shifting and actually I don't think
there is anything wrong with that we
just need to recognize it for what it is
and recognize that as you say
fundamentally the journey is the
destination yeah so all right what about
seek Clarity why is Clarity important
Clarity
so the first third of the book is about
how do we find ways to energize us and
make things feel more enjoyable so play
power in people uh the second third is
about how do we beat procrastination and
there are basically Three core blockers
that cause us to procrastinate from
stuff uncertainty fear and inertia and
so seeking Clarity is really about that
first
step if if someone has the goal of I
want to get fit what the hell does that
mean like they're going to procrastinate
on that for their entire life because
they have no idea what get fit actually
means like who who knows how do you
break that down students if they have
the goal of light onon us revised for my
chemistry exam it's like okay but what
does that mean are you reading a
textbook are you doing some practice
papers like there's a lot of mental
cognitive friction involved in trying to
figure out what the hell you're actually
trying to do and the point around
Clarity is that if you're ever
struggling with procrastination just ask
yourself am I actually clear on what I
need to do here am I clear on why I'm
doing it and am I clear on when I'm
going to do it what why and when and if
we can just get clear on those three
things that will cure procrastination
for the vast majority of people what's a
goal why is that a goal and okay cool
what's the next action and when and you
know when am I going to do it which is
why I'm so bullish on just putting a
thing in the calendar cuz once once it's
in the calendar at least then you have
sorted the clarity point and now if
you're still procrastinating from it now
there's probably some emotional issues
that we have to deal with but like at
least let's just get in the calendar and
Define what the task actually is so
that's the first step from a tactical
perspective for you absolutely yeah it's
it's got to be in the calendar I think
one of the best time management
strategies I've ever found is something
called the ideal week where you know a
lot of people say that they don't have
time they have never ending to-do list
um the ideal week is basically where you
create a blank Google Calendar you call
it your ideal week and you just block
out what does your ideal week look like
when would you like to wake up when
would you like to sleep when are your
gym times when when are your date nights
when are you at work and you realize by
by doing this that a you have more time
than you realize and also you have less
time than you realize because if you
wanted to do those 18 projects on your
to-do list and someone listening to this
is probably uh you know prodct somewhat
productivity minded wants to get a lot
of things done at a very high level you
realize there are simply not enough
hours in the day and that's okay that
means you can now eliminate the things
that really don't matter in focus of the
things that really do um and so so the
ideal week is a way of figuring out do I
actually have a manageable number of
things on my plate and once you do
putting them in your actual calendar is
a way of making sure you've made the
time for the thing have you thought
about how people can learn to say no
more effectively yeah we've got some
stuff in the book around this this is
something I I I really struggle with I
love Derek Civ thing of hell yeah or no
if it's not a hell yeah then it's then
it's a no I love the idea of never
saying yes uh over the phone or in
person and always being like that's
Daniel carman's thing right it is yeah
he never says yes over the phone
let me check my calendar and get back to
you I love to offload things to be like
you know what let me just check with my
team because they manage my calendar
because then I'm not the bad guy in
saying no to the thing um do you think
you're a people pleaser absolutely yeah
me too it's so bad dude yeah it's so bad
I've only just realized this recently I
I started doing therapy for the first
time properly in person in Austin the
lady that I've started working with
worked with a friend who was way way way
more of a bastard than I am and I
figured if she can deal with his [__]
she can definitely deal with my [__] so
he was the canary and the co mine and uh
yeah I just I don't know I think I think
I probably if I'd done enough self
assessment I would have realized that I
was a people pleaser but um it I think
it felt a bit emasculating to realize it
felt like I don't know cued or agreeable
or feminine or something that I just
didn't like the idea of and there's
still a lot with me of a vestigal like
um compensatory mechanisms from feeling
weak in school uh from being fragile and
bullied and stuff in school so I I don't
want to show that like new the
vulnerabilities that I already have I'm
happy to accept but new ones well no no
no no no no cuz that's just another
piece on the pile of you might be a
fragile weak piece of [__] right um but
this was a new one and it stared me in
the face for long enough during sessions
where I was like right okay I can't I
can't [__] I can't escape this I hate
telling people bad news I hate
disappointing people I somehow managed
to find a way to be able to blame myself
for something which was evidently
somebody else's fault let's say that
someone in the team messes up and gets
something wrong and it was completely on
them I feel bad about telling them that
they did something bad because it's
going to make them feel bad and I don't
want them to feel bad even though it was
their [__] fault y i what you mean
mate I have exactly the same like how
how how are you dealing with this any
tips
um a couple other things that have
helped a lot for me uh the big
Productions that I've done in person are
uh sufficiently high stakes that they've
pushed the boundary of what I'm prepared
to expect from people uh so for instance
we did what's seven episodes in three
days in London a couple of weeks ago I
need the guys to be on the ball for that
and I also need to be able to get people
to do things that I can't do like if I'm
hungry and I need a sandwich I need to
shout yo can someone get me a sandwich
like that previously would have been
like who the [__] am I to ask for a
sandwich what is this like oh can you
come and feed me grapes and fan me with
a leaf but like just formative
experiences where you need to make
commands and demands of other people
that's one another one has been um more
of a realization that the standards that
you hold yourself to are the minimum
standard that you should hold everybody
else to as well right like I know that I
work hard for all that there's a current
trend on the internet of uh laying all
of My Success at the feet of either love
island or the way that I look given that
this is yeah I I did a trigonometry
episode and they decided to call it uh
like the truth about confidence and um
it triggered some people on the internet
yeah which was hilarious uh given
especially given the fact that this is a
podcast which is bigger on audio
literally where my face doesn't exist
than on YouTube where it does anyway
yeah but your YouTube Banner is like you
doing that that's true but that's that's
not on Spotify it's just my [__] head
anyway
um that Insight
around I know that I work really really
hard I know that the standards that I
hold myself to are very high so saying
okay I should expect other people to at
least be in the same universe as me
shouldn't be something that you feel
guilty about it's like look if the guy
that's at one component within a team
whether you're the top of the tree or
you know at the bottom of the tree it
doesn't matter but if you're working
hard you can quite happily expect other
people to be like hey I did it my stuff
was done on time right so setting an
example I think as a people pleaser is
is good if you're a people pleaser who
also doesn't work hard that's going to
be a tough Circle to square because
you're not going to be able to set an
example and to say hey I did it my stuff
was done on time right um helping other
people understand why you're doing it so
as a good example there was a couple of
a couple of times where Dean had bucked
to go away at like bad times of the year
uh not through any fault of his own and
then we started to apply a lot more work
to him and I was like hey dude um me and
Chase got us stuff done you didn't get
your stuff done right like this is this
is just fact and he was like man I I I
do not want to be the bottleneck I'll
fix it I was like ah that was a nice way
to get past it so using yourself not in
a like mate I've already got my you know
not sort of making people feel
belittled
but starting 10 toes forward in like I
am doing my things everybody else needs
to follow along behind that that seems
to be a good a good route too but it's
hard man the people pleasing thing for
me is like I find it hard to uh upset
people on the podcast I find it hard to
tell people in my personal life things
that they don't want to hear all of the
you you it looks like it's resonating
with your soul 100% yeah this is
literally a I'm I'm I'm in the midst of
some like family drama that's literally
a result of me wanting to you know if
someone is upset with me then my default
is like [__] let me try and do whatever
I can to fix it and not hey you're in
the wrong yeah I'm not supposed to
[__] apologize for this yeah yeah
it's it's rough man I've got um do
Robert Glover No More Mr nicey I love
that book I've read it I read it every
few years and I would keep highlighting
the [__] out of it and doing the
exercise I've got him coming on in
January um so yeah I'm looking forward
to speaking to him maybe he'll be the
answer but I as with most things man you
know you become aware of something about
yourself that you're maybe not that
happy with and then you obsess about it
and you think oh my God this is like one
of the defining characteristics of my
pathology as a human and then you
realize oh no this is just one
ingredient in the entire meal of the
things that are wrong with me um but
yeah I it's also okay because people
love you for who you are of all of the
different maladies and stuff that you
could have being a people pleaser isn't
the worst but I do think that it'll be
interesting for me need to check in in a
couple of years time and be like hey
how's the people pleasing thing going um
you definitely get you know you look at
older people and they're a bit more
grumpy sometimes uh and they seem to be
less people pleasy so maybe it's just
going to come along for the ride as a
byproduct of getting older I don't know
uh one point on the on the therapy thing
so um our mutual friend Bill Perkins
when we were hung up with him in y in
Austin when I when we tried to teach you
to wake s yeah that that was a real fail
uh I don't know I think if I do it the
second time around the muscle memory
will Ki will in but I I was I was asking
him you know cuz obviously I love die
with zero made a video about it etc etc
I loved your interview with him by the
way that actually that interview with
him was a direct result of why I'm
currently like digital n adding around
the world W because before that
interview I was like oh I'll just rent a
home base in London and be based in
London after that interview I was like I
need to freaking go for it
like kids and blah blah blah yeah I me
the only reason that he came on the
podcast is because of your video about
him oh no way I learned about the book
from your YouTube channel brought bill
on the show Bill smashed it bill then
changed your digital Nomad thing and as
a part of your digital Nomad thing you
came to Austin where I introduced you to
Bill Perkins and then when we were in
Austin and on his freaking boat I asked
him what are the biggest Roi purchases
of his life and he said hands down
couples's therapy relationship coach and
so I've now started couple like
literally the following week I started
working with a couple therapists I I SL
relationships coach it has been
absolutely phenomenally gamechanging I
cannot recommend it highly enough to
literally anyone if you're in a
relationship then doing relationship
coaching with someone who's a
professional who has experienced the
full gamut of all of the [__] the
couples talk about and struggle with is
just incredibly helpful what's it done
for you why is it so useful it's really
useful because it's given me tools to
have conversations that I just didn't
really have before I think there are
some people who are really there are
some couples who are just amazing at
communication by default very few like
most couples do not say oh my God we
communicate so much like we're just so
good at communication literally every
couple says like yeah man relationships
are hard communication's the main thing
and so one of those things is like you
know it's going to sound
potentially simple but
um listening out for the listening out
for the needs behind what the other
person is feeling like if the other
person is upset with anything or sad or
angry or frustrated or hurt any of these
emotions there is always a core need
that they have that is not being met and
instead of kind of talking at the level
of is the fridge door left open or
closed or is are we going here or there
it's like what's the core need does she
have oh she has a need for feeling
empowered when it comes to decision-
making ah okay so now that we know what
the need is and then usually if if you
describe a need to someone they're like
yeah that's it like I have a need for
fairness and contribution in the
relationship and when we kind of landed
on that on those two needs I was that
really yeah that's literally it like
those two needs explain a lot of my
behaviors in relationships and outside
of relationships without the other
person's perspective presumably you
would just get caught up at what the
problems are at the top not what the
subtext is that sits below exactly and
this is where I think you know I I would
say my IQ is reasonable but my EQ is
probably lower than I would like it to
be so the thing I thing I'm working on
and so when my girlfriend and I would
have issues around like I don't know
planning a trip I would get caught up in
the level of like okay but you know I've
got my book coming out and you know it's
important for me that we go to La to do
this podcast or you know all this sort
of stuff but when I realize that she has
a need to feel empowered in decision-
making I'm like oh I can just get her
involved in the decision making about
this where do you want to go I'll find a
podcast that's in that c yeah but also
like hey let's approach this as a team
as a conversation rather than me doing
all the working in my head and coming so
this is another big realization if
someone were to say to me if my partner
were to say to me Ali you know for the
next 3 months I've got everything
planned don't you worry about it like
just come along for the ride and you
know you know life's going to be great
we're going to go southeast Asia I would
think thank the Lord that's incredible I
love that someone else is making the
making the decisions here I can focus on
my work which is the thing I care about
life is good whereas for my girlfriend
that same Arrangement makes her feel
disempowered and is therefore terrible
and so a lot of the coup therapy and
relationship coaching is recognizing
that the patterns of thought that we
think are so natural to us are
absolutely not necessarily natural for
the other person and just understanding
that it's like oh okay you have a need
for connection and that is solved by
having a a cuddle in the morning for a
minute great that's easy enough or like
you know hugging when we greet each
other it's not a thing that I would that
in the calendar not yet cuddle cuddle
cuddle in the morning one minute it's in
the habit tracker right okay um so it's
just been super super helpful in that
and on on that front just as as a way of
us being better at communicating would
recommend what about sustaining so you
know what we've spoken about finding a
way to make things more enjoyable
overcoming procrastination but but then
doing this along a long period of time
you know the next 10 20 30 40 Years of
your working life your creative life is
what really matters I think I I heard
you say on a podcast recently um the
reason that you'd been successful was a
combination of a tiny little bit of
talent mostly look and good timing with
consistency pretty much yeah yeah this
is the thing so anyone can be who who
super productive or super disciplined
for a short amount of time January yeah
January like the first two weeks of
January very few of us can actually
sustain that unless we really put effort
into what does consistency and
sustainable sustainability look like um
and one of my favorite Morgan how Morgan
hle quotes is I'm not going to do
anything unless I can do it forever and
that's a really good way of thinking
about it um and so I kind of boil it
down to three things three tools that
help combat burnout and that lead to
more sustainability and productivity let
conserve recharge and align and of these
three strategies tackles a different
aspect of burnout so broadly three three
three different types of burnout there
is uh overexertion burnout you're just
trying to do too much [__] depletion
burnout where your energy levels are
Solo and you're not giving yourself the
chance to replenish your energy levels
and then misalignment burnout which is
sometimes the hardest one to deal with
which is where everything seems to be
going well but actually what the actions
you are taking in the here and now are
not aligned with the future that you
actually intrinsically want for yourself
maybe maybe it's something other people
are expecting of you or whatever the
thing might be and so those three things
really stop stuff from being sustainable
conserve how do we do that conserve is
basically about recognizing that a we
need to limit the amount of things that
we're doing because one of one of the
issues with to-do lists is that uh they
are infinite and you can always keep
adding stuff to a to-do list and so a
lot of people who want to be high
performers and productivity Bros and
stuff will just keep adding things to
their to their to-do list and think you
know what i' I've got to juggle all
these balls in the air but one of the
things I love about Oliver burkman's
Philosophy from 4,000 weeks is there is
simply too much [__] to do and you will
never have enough time for any of it for
for all of it therefore you have to make
some
sacrifices um the way I I personally do
this is you know this ideal week method
if it doesn't fit in the ideal week I
don't have time for it um but also
something that I call the energy
Investment Portfolio which is basically
I have a Long bucket list in a sort of
can band board but you can do it however
you want I have a Long bucket list of
things I would like to do and then I
have a very short list of the three to
five things I'm actually putting I'm
actually investing energy into right now
and so back in the day I made the
mistake in lockdown of like yeah I've
got so much time I'm going to have
guitar lessons and singing lessons and
piano lessons and art lessons because I
want to learn all this stuff let me try
and learn some Japanese on the side just
doing too much stuff um making focused
progress in a few in a few small D in a
few small some small number of things is
way more effective than trying to you
know make a thousand uh one mod of
progress in a thousand different
directions
so a big part of conserve is actually
just this this thing of learning to say
no and getting things off our plate um I
really like a strategy uh that's called
the uh the six week trap which is if you
imagine yourself someone's asking you to
do a thing it's more than six weeks out
you look at your calendar more than six
weeks out it's pretty chill right the
calendar is looking pretty blank oh
glorious yeah I'm around I can totally
do that thing and obviously the time
rolls around the Calendar's gotten full
up again you're completely overwhelmed
and you're like [__] [__] I shouldn't
have said yes to that thing if you
wouldn't do it tomorrow don't say yes
for in 6 months time exactly um and so
conserve is really a about kind of
limiting the number of things that we're
doing and B also kind of on a micro
level actually just focusing on one
thing at a time this is again classic
stuff that everyone knows but you know
the idea of um kind of switching costs
and attention residues switching between
multiple tasks means you're just less
efficient at each of them and you're
draining you're you're wasting a lot of
by not being by not doing things one at
a time um and so the the basic stuff
that people know but like you know I
found myself I was reading the audiobook
for this a couple couple weeks ago and
it was really the third the final three
chapters where I was like oh my God I
need to take my own advice cuz I was
feeling overwhelmed I had too much stuff
on my calendar I felt all of it was
important but it really wasn't and as I
was narrating the audiobook for those
chapters I was I was like okay action
point there action point there let me
actually do
this it's strange I mean even just that
Insight that the guy who wrote the book
doesn't always necessarily take the
advice that he wrote down I think is is
good for people to know it's important
for people to know because one of the
problems that some people that listen to
this podcast tell me about is I hear all
of these great strategies and I get
overwhelmed with how many of the
different things there are that I could
do that I could apply to my own life and
it seems like everybody else has got
their [__] together it's like look let
me promise you I've been around some of
the most famous successful High status
people on the planet and it's idiots all
the way up y right it's people who do
not know what they're doing they haven't
gotten everyone is trying their best and
failing that's the one I was listening
to uh Mark Manson's interview with
Morgan hell yesterday on a run because
part of my thing is like I I want to do
30 minutes of exercise each day and one
of the things that Mark said was you
know once he became rich and had all
these problems around like status and
money and things like that you know
boohoo he read his book and he realized
oh [__] all of the principles in the
subtle I'm not giving a [__] apply to
this exact situation that I'm currently
in I just didn't realize it and so took
his own advice so the book that made him
famous and successful contained in it
the answers to the problems of his Fame
and success exactly and he didn't
realize that until like a couple of
years after suffering through the
suffering suffering through the problems
of the application of stuff the
application of these ideas of everything
that we go through this is why I love uh
Tim Ferris idea the good [__] sticks
it's like the most robust way I think to
get over Guild of your
external brain Evernote not being
perfectly optimized or you know your
[__] ebbing house forgetting curve
anky space repetition thing not
reminding you of all of the quotes that
you want to like look if there's
something from one podcast a week or one
book per month that you can't stop
thinking about that's the thing right
that is the thing it's self- selected
for it like mimetic Evolution inside of
your own mind that's the thing that you
need to work on what can you not stop
telling people about screen recording it
sending it in group chats it's written
on a post it not like that's the thing
the good [__] will stick and everything
else can fall away again this is like um
it's like Feelgood productivity it's
like feel resonance uh like uh
progression yeah right what is the thing
that you can't stop thinking about
that's the thing that you can focus on
because it's the easiest thing for you
to not not stop thinking about yeah I
think this point around like you
know there's in in this book initially
there was twice as long and there were
twice as many strategies and our editor
was like bro we need to cut them down
and even now there are nine chapters you
know 54 actionable experiments that
people can apply in their life but you
know the whole thing that I'm trying to
get across in this book is that the goal
is not to apply all 54 at once the goal
is to apply them one at a time and see
see what Vibes see what problem you are
having in your life right now I mean you
know there's no such thing as a problem
but like what situation you're trying to
deal with what is a strategy that might
help try it out for yourself does it
work does it not cool either way it's an
experiment you've gained data and you
can see how to make it work work for you
for some people you know they realize
the way to be consistent at the gym is
to do it first thing in the morning for
some people they do realize it's in the
afternoon for some people it's an
accountability bodyy for some people
it's doing CrossFit for some people it's
tracking their workouts using an app
it's different things for different
people but the point is as long as you
are finding the things that work for you
and not trying to overload your brain by
doing all of them at once that is kind
of this path of continuous and never
never ending Improvement recharge
recharge um there's a fun experiment
that I I I like to ask people when they
say that they're struggling or like
burned out or anything like that which
is what are the things you find yourself
doing when you are drained of energy and
then separately what are the things that
actually recharge your energy your
energy so for example when I find myself
drained of energy I will default to
scrolling on Twitter or Instagram or
whatever randomly opening YouTube for no
reason randomly refreshing my YouTube
analy it's like okay but what are the
things that actually recharge my energy
do any of those things have I ever left
a scrolling session from Tik Tok feeling
whoa wow feel so refreshed absolutely
not I don't think any I don't know
anyone who's left a scrolling session on
Tik Tok feeling feeling really refreshed
again I'm not saying Tik Tok is bad but
like you know broadly I'm I'm in favor
of people doing the things in doing
things intentionally if for you
scrolling Instagram and watching cooking
videos or whatever the thing is in fact
recharges your energy then great you are
in the very small minority of people for
most of us it does not and so part of
recharging is to recognize that hey I
care about my energy levels my energy
levels affect my entire life because
when we are feeling high energy we feel
happier more fulfilled more productive
sure so let me actually just do the
things and incorporate things into my
life that genuinely recharge my energy
unfortunately this is the basic [__]
sleeping well doing some exercise having
a app spending some time in nature
creative hobbies are very recharging um
you know this is why painting is a great
hobby that a lot of people land on as
being a thing knitting crocheting any
anything like that that like gives us
that feeling that we are making progress
that we have autonomy low stakes low
stakes yeah you're not trying to
monetize it too much like all of that
stuff it's important to have creative
Hobbies generally recharges your energy
way more than watching Netflix or
scrolling Tik Tok so there's a a vicious
cycle here I came up with this idea of
productivity Purgatory I think I told
you about this before but productivity
Purgatory is when the things that you do
to enjoy life and recharge are only done
in order to facilitate your productivity
when you stop doing them right so you
don't go for a walk in nature because
you want to enjoy your time in nature
you do it because you once listen to an
Andrew hubman podcast that said 15
minutes of sunlight in the improves your
dopaminergic response which means that
you can be 5% more productive that day
right productivity Purgatory describes
an environment in which nothing that you
do is not for productivity and it's
dangerous right and this is something
it's like recharge is both a
productivity strategy but also a life
piece of advice right you need to do
things that are not just the thing that
involves work even if you absolutely
love work you can't keep doing it your
work will benefit from this but it can't
be in service of the work or else you
end up in productivity Purgatory uh this
is the thing like you been rereading the
power of now and it's just it's just
some such a good advice you know do the
thing for the sake of the thing itself
the way that I'm trying to apply this is
in the shower each morning because in
the shower is like a clear place where
if you know like I look forward to
Mondays I love hanging out with my team
and like doing the work stuff and I
sometimes find myself thinking oh I just
want to get to the end of the shower so
that I can like get get involved with
the team I'm like no what the [__] am I
doing like I'm having a hot shower the
present moment is literally all there is
and I just need to remind myself okay
I'm having a shower to have a shower not
so that I can then do my hair and stuff
and film that next video I'm going for a
walk to Simply go for a walk not so that
I can actually get my steps in while
also consuming the audiobook at three
times speed yeah and that is a again it
it comes back to this idea of holding
holding seemingly conflicting ideas in
mind at the same time one idea which is
that you know the happiness of pursuit
it's like pursuing stuff feels very dope
and energic but also enjoying the
present moment and focusing on it is a
very contented place to be yeah so
there's George Mack has this idea of
dopamine George and serotonin George oh
yeah and he says I want to spend as much
time in serotonin George as I can
dopamine George looks after himself like
dopamine George is a cocaine addict
serotonin George is a quiet guitar
player and spending more time in saraton
now there's a third one that I want to
start talking about with him soon uh
which is ctis all George uh and ctis all
George is somewhere between like he's
even further down the line than dopamine
George is it's frantic it's like kind of
like tense and and uncomfortable but
yeah man you know a lot of the people
oxytocin George oxto cuddling true I
guess that's on the other side of seroni
George but yeah man you know everyone
spends way too much time in dopamine
whoever they are you know it's using the
power of progression and targets and
achievement and money and extrinsic
motivation and all of that sort of stuff
and even intrinsic motivation of oh wow
I got better at that thing like that's
fantastic but how many hours this year
did you spend lying underneath a tree
like that's a good metric for uh
serotonin Ali or serotonin Chris or
serotonin George yeah I think this is
why why also also why I love the you
know honestly the main thing that I I've
taken away from writing this book is
just the title feel good productivity
because there it's seemingly
contradictory because productivity is
always about Pursuit and feeling good is
about enjoying the moment and both of
those things are okay and we just you
know if we're doing both we are really
really winning working towards of of
fulfilling life enjoying the dopamine
and also enjoying the cotoni along the
way we spoke about this on stage in
front of maybe a thousand people in
Brighton a couple of months ago and you
kind of uh reveal the end of the book
which is what a lot of people might have
thought would have been at the start of
it which is to do with what are you
actually working on like what are the
goals that you're choosing to do why put
that at the end of of the book yeah so
initially when I did the first draft of
the book the first chapter was about
figuring out your direction in life cuz
my my whole idea was like look
productivity fine but there's no point
in driving 100 miles in a particular
direction if you find out it was the
wrong direction to drive in and so a big
part of productivity is really asking
yourself the question of what are the
things I'm working on and why am I
working on them but it was a bit heavy
for chapter one and I didn't want the
conclusion to be hey I I don't enjoy my
job therefore Al telling me the only
thing I can do is quit my job and follow
my passion like that's that's not the
that's not the vibe It's the Final
Chapter
because and it's called align because
it's about aligning your actions in the
here and now with where you actually
want to go and it's a final chapter
because even if you're not there yet you
know most people listening to this are
probably probably don't have the level
of autonomy and freedom that you and I
do having grinded at this [__] while
enjoying the process for a very long
time you prob if you have a day job and
you don't enjoy the day job the solution
is not the Sol the the way to get to
feel good productivity is not too simp
quit the quit the day job is to try all
the other things first find a way to
approach it with play and power get a
find a way to get people involved make
sure you're not procrastinating make
sure you're doing the right things to
recharge your energy once you have done
all of those things if you are still
feeling that you know my the things I'm
doing don't feel aligned I still I'm
getting this misalignment burnout at
that point it's now time for us to start
thinking about the big questions so one
strategy I really enjoy that I think is
super helpful for everyone to do is to
just write their own obit I did this a
couple months ago it was pretty eye
opening and and is this idea that Steven
cvy talks about as well begin with the
end in mind there is something about
imagining yourself on your deathbed
surrounded by loved ones and imagining
what would they say at my funeral what
are they saying around me what would my
obituary read that really helps get rid
of the [__] of like what doesn't
matter and helps us focus on what really
does which is often relationships rather
than work so that's one useful strategy
um he always answered his emails on time
and he was really great at keeping the
notion template up to date no and he
drove 7% returns for our hedge fund
every year it's like no one no one gives
a [__] it's like you know he was humble
he enjoyed spending time with people
around him he energized the people
around him he was always there for us he
was supportive he was kind he was
warm Darren Brown and his book happy
which is about stoicism has a really
good idea that I I often come back to
which is we think people want impressive
but actually what they want is just warm
and warmth is way more important than
impressiveness and in like networking
events when when meeting people it's
like people will often try and present
some sort
of I'm impressive because XYZ but
actually a lot of people just want want
warmth um and so beginning with the end
in mind thinking what would I want
people to say on my deathbed what would
I want written on my gravestone can be a
really helpful way of thinking is the
way that I'm currently living aligned
with what I would like that to be one of
the things that I've always struggled
with and I felt you know I came up
through through the trenches of
productivity you know seven or eight
years ago because I was adamant that the
solution there's more there because I
was adamant that the solution was uh if
only I had a perfectly designed notion
template all of my problems would go
away and one of the tools that's often
in there is begin with the end in mind
you know uh start with a uh 25 year long
outcome broken down into fiveyear like
marathons broken down into onee metag
gos broken down into 90-day Sprints
broken down into daily actions broken
down into micro disciplines right okay
fantastic like I understand I understand
why that sort of stuff works 25e
goals 5ye goals one year goals one year
goal is just about is on the very very
brink of what I can do I'm so bad at
long-term planning I'm so bad at knowing
what I want to do over the long term and
it used to I I I appreciate the fact
that you say um not putting the goals
thing at the beginning was a strategy
done to try and help people get moving
because there's easier steps that you
can go along that path because I'm very
much that sort of a person a lot of the
uh strategy planning and goal like
productivity planning systems that I
came across I fell at the first hurdle
because that goal setting thing for me
just really really struggled to resonate
what is better
about the
obituary solution I suppose is it's not
about what are the outcomes that you
want it's about what is the feeling and
the sense that you want to have left
behind it's not saying what's your net
worth going to be at age 80 uh how many
YouTube videos who will you have created
what is the sort of setup of the company
that you want it's much more viby yeah
right exactly it's all about the vibe I
think I also tried the whole like figure
out a 50-year plan and break it down
into five-year chunks method and I was
just like come on like my life is so
different now than it was even two or
three years ago like there's no way in
hell I could even vaguely begin to
predict what what the future looks like
but the way I found to square this is to
recognize that the further out we go the
fuzzier the destination becomes but
that's okay because the point of the
destination is to give us a direction
it's not actually the destination itself
and you can check in and continue to
readjust absolutely yeah but I mean the
vibe is very unlikely to change right I
want people to
feel understood
seen warm less
fearful like comfortable in my presence
I want I want to leave the world in a
better place than I arrived at it uh in
a way that is enlightening and hopefully
not too serious like okay and that's the
same across my friends my family the
people that I talk to on the internet
all of that stuff all right none of
those things really have
any none of it comes to bear on the
business organization that I have or the
revenue or the videos or any of that
sort of stuff or you know it's do I
arrive on time for dinner with my
friends right do I have enough respect
for my friends that I'm going to make
sure that I set off early and arrive on
time it's like little decisions like
that those are really what I think ultim
timately you're going
to define the kind of memories that you
leave
behind yeah I I also Vibe with what you
said around ye uh one-year plans well
one- year plan is also the the longest
time Horizon that I can feasibly plan in
and even then you know the way the way I
think of it is in each different domain
of life and there are like nine of them
three in health work and relationships
you split the pie however you want in in
each of those different domains what am
I celebrating 12 months from now so in
my work life around like learning you
know i' I'd love to celebrate actually
becoming really really good at
understanding the the longevity stuff
been wanting to do it for a while it's
like cool I'd like to celebrate that in
my romantic life you know I'd like to
celebrate getting married cool easy in
my friendships I'd like to celebrate the
fact that every quarter we went on like
a little lad's road trip okay cool now
those are my those are my goals and now
I can employ all my productivity
strategies of like you know putting in
the ideal week making sure I've got time
writing it down on my projects list to
just remind myself that this this is a
thing that I actually care about because
otherwise we get caught up in the
day-to-day of life and we forget that oh
yeah I was meant I did intend to
organize a trip with my friends every
few months haven't done that in a while
you know I've got a spare half an hour
now why don't I just do some research on
Airbnb just those little reminders is
where I think productivity strategies
are super super helpful but becoming
obsessed with the systems um then kind
of detracts from everything else in life
well it's turning the bar stool upside
down right productivity is there to
facilitate the outcomes that you want to
you want to achieve and those should be
Downstream from the vibe and the sort of
life that you want right it shouldn't be
I'm going to employ productivity
strategies and allow the vibe of my life
to occur out of those they don't it
doesn't grow out of the productivity
strategies so this is going to be out
December 26 that's right in the US
December 28th worldwide okay uh this
episode's going to drop like December
19th so people can go and pre- buy it
now on Amazon Ali abdal Feelgood
productivity what's this keyboard oh
this keyboard This is a tech brand
called light mode that we are in the
process of launching it will have
launched by the time this is out hell
yeah um we're trying to do like
productivity desk accessories stuff in
your bag all that kind of stuff but not
aimed at Gamers aimed at like people who
like the Apple aesthetic a little bit
who want things to be a little bit more
light and free and playful and stuff so
this is our mechanical keyboard how long
have you been working on that M this is
like like two-year long process to try
and find the perfect click and the
perfect switch and the perfect amount of
lube Lube to put on the keys and the
perfect weight of the metal plate and
all that I think about Lube research
actually that is one of the first places
that I go to yeah man uh so people can
check that out if they want if if you're
interested in a clacky sounding
mechanical keyboard that light mode.com
light mode.com exactly hell yeah allly I
appreciate you uh I look forward to
seeing how this book gets on you you
know that you're going to smash it it's
like it's very much needed I think and
given that we're about to go into the
new year and people are going to be
thinking right I need to get my S
together new year new me new
productivity strategy there's the book
yeah hopefully it's helpful for some
people H yeah and good luck with your
drink as well it's super nice thank my
one if you enjoyed that episode then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
weeks and don't forget to subscribe